alle vergaben etliche kommen heute zu
einem neuen videospiel heute ein spiel
freunde ich die klasse das neue call of
duty free wir da kann einpacken
al-gaddafi falls dann einfach auf
deutsch übersetzt da befindet sich
scheiße in meiner super also das ist für
die mode nicht einfach mal runtergeladen
ich würde sagen ich denke einfach mal
das denn
roger park das sieht richtig komplexer
hoster ich werde ehrlich gesagt nicht
auf was ich drücken soll ich rücke schon
überall mal hin so das bringt ja okay
ich kann etwas bewegen und linke die
eine karte eingeblendet heißt sie können
genau wie wo ich mich gerade befindet
ich glaube ich kann mir nicht in die
sonne
ich kann ich wirklich leute mit weiter
werfen als wenn ich das richtig
beurteilen bin ich das hier oben und ihr
seht schon wieder die obama fans drücken
dann packt er scheiterte aus dem mund
und wird leute ab
und er der zeit okay leute wartet man
die kraft treten
ich werde jetzt eine im stehen gehen ab
als ich wäre viel humor und ok das hat
nicht geklappt hier normal
congratulations to post a game and drums
inzwischen bei camera control the bomb
es gibt oft booking bonner ich weiß
ehrlich gesagt nicht wie du das spiel
der buchinhalt weil hier nicht irgendwie
mit scheiße oder so
ok ich glaube ich damit die bombe frei
geschaltet das ganze spiel nichts mit
irgendeiner verkauften suppe zu tun aber
der titel heißt das buch in das ich
überhaupt keinen sinn ich weiß nicht wie
ich die bombe einsätze deswegen darf
nicht einfach mal weiter hier mit
scheiße einfach auf die leute zu
das geht jetzt nicht das ding von modus
ist der gleiche ausgeschaltet ist und
ich bin quasi
das war eine combo und ich hab die
gerade versaut okay leute ich werde
jetzt den vogel ab ob salanders hatte
ich jetzt geklappt aber
3 oder 1 nach besser alter da unten ist
eine suppe da zeitlich versuche jetzt
einfach mal in die suppe reinzuwerfen
das hat jetzt nichts gebracht ihr recht
auch eine kugel ist also nicht eine
schule sondern eine coole da sehen wir
die ganzen sachen die wir machen müssen
wenn wir das dann alles frei geschaltet
haben dann kriegen wir 25 putts
die midlife wahrscheinlich wenn ich den
vogel ab werk oder so das probiere ich
einfach mal erlebt also ich klicke
einfach hier und nehmen hier noch
richtig viel aufbauen 441 habe ich die
zwar geschafft leute ich weiß ehrlich
gesagt nicht ob mir die worte ob
oettinger die bohne getroffen
ich weiß immer noch nicht ehrlich gesagt
wie ich diese bombe einsätze also ich
würde sagen der war hier noch ein
bisschen weiter vor habe jetzt als boa
diesmal 675 alter den fahrtwind paar
sekunden später
es gibt denn jetzt ab alter ich dachte
wirklich das wetter behindert ich will
was irgendwie einfach nur bei gamesload
angezeigt hätte eigentlich in behinderte
spiel hört einfach drei games oder
getränk würde ich versuche diesmal
wirklich sehr sehr vorsichtig vorzugehen
also nicht alles irgendwie schauen
sondern wirklich jede scheibe irgendwie
auf mann zu bringen so die armee die
nächsten unlock people
das ist der mit ihm los alltag hier
unten 100 dennoch auf wen geht genau
dann hier auf das kleine kind weil ihr
wird natürlich alle kinder die kammer
nur mit das verdammte bombe einsätze
alter gibt es nicht
es gibt auch locker irgendeine partei
hier wenn ich die brücke dass ich eine
bombe
ich gebe darauf heftig zum korb nbv zu
leuten die hier vielleicht irgendwie
fast normal scheiße abwerfen leute ich
will einfach nur wissen wie diese
verdammte bombe abwerfe 1204 dort baku
at me ich gehe ganz kurz zurückgeben und
das sehen wir schon feste pubertät
huayra ich habe überhaupt keinen plan
wie ich irgendwie die bombe einsetzt
nicht hier oben drauf hin dass ihre
überlegt ok diesmal habe ich als 19.000
451 leute okay ich würde sagen das kann
jetzt auf jeden fall besser machen die
sache teilt auch das einfach mehr leute
kommen glaube ich das heißt ich schmeiße
einfach die seite die ganze zeit runter
und so wird sie nicht schon das einfach
einmal mehr leute hier irgendwie sport
und ich habe auch mehr scheint irgendwie
verteilen kann das heißt es ist nicht so
dass verspielt von seite zu seite
schlechter wird bürgerkrieg pause es ist
wirklich nicht so dass das spiel
irgendwie mit zunehmender dauer
schwieriger wird oder dafür irgendwie
schwieriger ding macht andere
freizuschalten oder was weiß ich
die sache ist einfach nur wieder 45.000
leichter weil einfach mehr leute kommen
man hat mehr zeit die man irgendwie
verteilen kann
er darf fortan von der bombe weiter ich
bin echt mal gespannt was ich jetzt fünf
vorhaben werde leute am 86.000 junge
dadurch kann man sich aber verabschieden
wenn es euch gefallen hat leute das
gerne waren like da wie gesagt es war
heute einfach nur ein bescheuertes
spiele warten jetzt feierlich bin total
kaputt auch schon ein bisschen später
geworden deswegen hält das like darin
gleich gefallen hat uns schreibt zeit in
die kunst findet jetzt hier oben ein
smiley 1 gewertet wenn er darauf könnt
ihr kostenlos main kanal abonnieren
verpasst dadurch keine videos mehr mega
tolle funktion ich tue so als ob youtube
grad entdeckte laut verdi auch mit shop
eingeblendet in dem am ersten juni eine
neue sommerprojekt relaunchen freue ich
mich schon sehr oft megacoolen hier
unten ist ein anderes video verlinkt so
gut vertraut